hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast exploring the stoichiometry of
macromolecular complexes using multi
signal sedimentation velocity analytical
ultracentrifugation by dr. chad
Brautigam i am dr. trash warts senior
application scientist at beckman coulter
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we were delighted to bring you
this educational webinar presented by
lab roots and sponsored by Beckman
culture beckman coulter is a leader in
centrifugation and flow cytometry and
has long been an innovator and particle
characterization way of automation and
genomics beckman coulter products are
used at the forefront of important areas
of investigation discovery for more
information please visit Beckman culture
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left for the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge a
slide window by clicking on the icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
if you have any technical problems
viewing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems to the green Q&A button I
would not like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Chad Brautigam dr. Brautigam
arndell undergraduate degrees in
chemistry and biochemistry and molecular
cellular and developmental biology at
the University of Colorado Boulder he
then joined Thomas Stites lab at Yale
University where he studied the
structural enzymology of DNA polymerases
following the word of his PhD in
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
dr. Brad agam's postdoctoral work was in
the laboratory of Johan decent offer at
the University of Texas Southwestern
Medical Center why while inductor decent
offers lab he determined the
three-dimensional structures of proteins
involved in neuro plasticity and blue
light sensing implants it was at this
time that dr. bragging first developed
an interest in analytical
ultracentrifugation in 2007 he joined
the fact faculty of utsw advancing to
the rank of associate professor in the
department in the department of
biophysics and 2012 dr. brad egham is
also the director of mac molecular
biophysics resource a core laboratory
offering training in
access to a variety of biophysical
techniques he has served as an
instructor at UC workshops around the
world for over eight years additionally
dr. Brautigam developed software for
biophysical data processing analysis and
presentation these include read eight
and goosey which both act on a you see
data before we get started I would let I
would like to ask a few poll questions
our first poll question is what
instrument instrumentation do you
currently use determined particle
interactions particle size and
heterogeneity you can answer multiple
questions here analytical
ultracentrifugation the topic of the day
service plasmon resonance dynamic light
scattering nuclear magnetic resonance or
others will take a few moments and we'll
let the answers populate
okay just a few more seconds it looks
like about thirty-five percent use
analytical ultracentrifugation
thirty-five percent also use dynamic
light scattering nuclear NMR or nuclear
magnetic resonance comes in at eight
percent SPR or surface plasmon resonance
comes in at four percent and there are
other techniques as well that are coming
in at nineteen percent one additional
poll question before I turn it over to
dr. Brautigam for what types of analyses
are you interested in using analytical
ultracentrifugation again multiple
answers are allowed heterogeneity
reversible and non-reversible hetero
associations self associations molecular
weight determination and shape and size
determination will take about 10 to 15
seconds to allow everybody in the
audience to answer
great looks like thirty one percent are
interested in shape and size
determination twenty-eight percent are
interested in heterogeneity twenty-two
percent in just molecular weight
determination and at nine point four
percent we have two results at
reversible and non-reversible as hetero
associations and also self associations
all these methods are capable in the
analytical ultracentrifuge thank you
everybody for your answers and I would
now like to turn it over to dr. brouder
game for his presentation hello
everybody thanks for tuning in and
thanks to Chad for the introduction as
he mentioned i'll be speaking to you
today about the the technique of multi
signal sedimentation velocity i will go
over my title again so i just want very
briefly first of all to thank the
organizers for letting me speak to you
today those would include the people
beckman coulter particularly Lindsey
Schwarzkopf and Chet Schwartz and the
people will add labrada to helped out
with the technical aspects of getting
this to you mainly on Don Cruikshank so
I just wanted to go over with you what
the goal on multi signal sedimentation
velocity experiment is first of all
generally we can say that the goal is to
resolve amounts of materials that are
hydrodynamically not resolved
specifically then in an analytical to
segregation experiment what we're really
talking about there is that things that
have the same segmentation coefficient
now for most of you who have tuned in
what this really probably means is that
you want to
figure out the relative amounts of
species in a co sedimenting complex in
other words you have two species that
are interacting and moving together as
one entity during the cementation
velocity experiment so together with
multi single sedimentation velocity we
and we get both molar ratio and
hydrodynamic information on size shape
and molar mass and that allows us to get
the what i would call these be true
stone counter in the complex what I'm
saying there is let's say distinct from
a still County you might get as the
let's say n value from a calorimetric
experiment for instance let's say you
get to the run from that experiment that
might be actually for two or six to
three and that might have profound
implications for the mechanism of your
complex and say you want to know that
and multi single sedimentation velocity
is an excellent way to get at that
particularly if you're interested in
modeling your complex and so on this
slide I shadow basically a standard
sedimentation velocity experiment over
here on the Left we have the data and
you'll see that the data presented us as
data points purple here showing early
time scans red showing late time scans
and there are actually fits to these
data shown a solid lines if we do a
standard C of s analysis and we get the
the CFS distribution shown over here on
the right now that shows us that there's
a one thing they're sedimenting at about
five cents fed birds what isn't told in
this distribution is that there are
actually two things present but from a
single signal there's no way for us to
decompose this gfs
distribution into the into its component
pieces okay so on this slide then I show
the same data actually taking a two
different signals you can see that
there's a amplitude difference in the
signal if we do a multi signal
sedimentation velocity experiment then
what we see is the distribution on the
right so now we get two distributions
one for let's say protein a and the
other less per let's say protein be one
red one blue by knowing the the signal
increments of protein a and protein B
and by collecting data at two signals we
can decompose that CMS distribution into
component distributions and knowing the
molar ratio from these CFS distributions
and the mass information that we get
from the analytical ultracentrifugation
experiment automatically then we get
this magical quantity still geometry
which is what we're after so in this
webinar i'll be going over some basics
of sedimentation velocity i think most
of you are probably pretty familiar with
this stuff but i want to know what we're
going to be talking a lot about how the
multi signal segmentation velocity
analysis works and we need to all be on
the same page then i'll talk about
specifically the theory immortal signal
how to run us an experiment how to
analyze the data and then threw out
there will be examples and at the end
we'll talk about a a problem case that
we worked out all right so this
animation then shows us the
phenomenology of cementation velocity
you can see it early times we have a
flat purple line and then at late times
we've got a flat red line and we have
this data trace going from left to right
across
your computer screen there and so what
we're seeing is a certain velocity of
the molecules moving toward the bottom
of the SEC torial centrifugation cell
and this region between between where
there is solute and where there isn't
solute is called the boundary and so
we're watching the boundary move toward
the bottom of the cell so from its
velocity we get the cementation
coefficient but you also notice that
these boundaries start flattening out as
we get later in later time that's
actually a measure of the diffusion
coefficient and so from such an
experiment we can get both the
cementation coefficient and the
diffusion coefficient this is the sped
brick equation I'm showing here so the
rest of the quantities here are
experimental quantities that we either
know or should know a gas constant and
temperature the partial specific volume
of the protein and row which is the
solution density since we know all those
things then we automatically get more
mass out of that so from a sanitation
velocity experiment we get sedimentation
coefficient diffusion coefficient often
encoded in terms of the frictional ratio
and molar mass okay so these are the
species properties that we might get
from a sedimentation velocity experiment
the the equation that governs basically
what the data looks like is called the
the lamb equation and that's shown here
it's a partial differential equation and
you can see that we have our our old
friends diffusion coefficient and
sedimentation coefficient shown in there
there's some other things in here radius
from the center of rotation the weight
concentration of the species the angular
velocity of the rotor and so when we put
all that together we get this over here
on the left which is basically the
change in concentration as a function of
time and so that's what we're going to
looking at when we look at solutions to
the lamb equation just in case you're
curious basically there are no exact
analytical solutions to the lamb
equation but it's pretty easy to solve
it numerically and in fact every program
that I know that does the the task of
solving the lamb equation does it
numerically and it uses this clavering
finite element approach which is briefly
shown here I don't want to belabor this
too much but you can see that what we
get here are resolved is concentration
as a function of radius and time that's
going to be the sum of a bunch of these
triangular hat functions so those are
shown here they are just trying other
functions if we add them all up what's
saying in the beginning would have a
uniform distribution if we added all
those up don't be a straight line right
across the board but at a later time
will be scaling them by these age
factors here and then at a later time
those age factors times those hat
functions would look like this when we
add all that up when we end up getting
is something that looks like that which
is the basically something that looks
like our data and so all data are
modeled with these numerical solutions
to the lamb equation so this is a
solution to the lamb equation starting
from unitary concentration basically
this was a a simulation for a species
that had a segmentation coefficient of
2s and a diffusion coefficients of 2.3
fix so you can see again shown in purple
we have early time points and in red we
have late time points and each one of
these stands then or is basically a
moment frozen in time so my point here
is that the lamb equation holds for all
radii so we
for all radii and it holds for all time
so we've solved it for all times and
then just displayed discrete times shown
in this graph now the data basically are
going to look like the figure on the
left what we can do is basically fit
land equations solutions which look like
this to our data and and that's actually
a fairly straightforward thing to do
basically what we end up doing is a bit
solving the lamb equation with
segmentation coefficient and diffusion
coefficient as fitted parameters and
then we scale it by a concentration
parameter which basically allows us to
fit it into signal space so I point out
here that data are in signal space so
our solutions to lamb equation have to
be transformed into that space with the
C factor here AR T is going to be our
raw data and so these data I'm actually
showing are not simulated Jesus this was
actually for experiment I ran back in
July and you can see that the
segmentation coefficient refined to 3.2
the molar mass which is related to the
diffusion coefficient of course refined
to 39,000 678 grams per mole so we can
actually use these land equation
solutions to fit the data directly in
data space now sometimes we have dated
that are a little bit more complicated
for example here we have two boundaries
and just in case you're not used to
looking at data what you have to look at
the later time points one of the
boundaries is there the other boundary
is there so we have a fast-moving
component and a slow-moving component
for complex mixture of species than what
we use is a bunch of lamb equation
solutions so what we're going to do is
instead of using a single concentration
factor to scale our land equation
solutions we're going to use a
distribution of them called the sea of s
distribution most of you are probably
familiar with this this is the goat
method for the analysis of sedimentation
velocity data so we have our data in the
data space we have a CFS distribution
which must be relating a bunch of lamb
equation solutions to that data space
and operationally in the program what
happens as we discretize this integral
and we have a resolution showing as
little m here of a bunch of C values and
those are all scaling a bunch of
respective lamb equation solutions what
this ends up looking like is the
distribution shown over here on the left
so if we have a distribution that looks
like this we scale this times the
respective lamb equation solutions add
it all up and ends up looking like the
solid lines here which are the fits to
the data so the CFS distribution is
basically a distribution of more or less
concentration factor as those signal
concentration factors that are scaling
the lamb equation solutions to fit our
data in data space okay now an
interesting aspect of the CMS
distribution is that it's normalized
such that it is differential so if we
integrate this peak in our C of s
distribution what we end up getting is
the signal concentration of that's lower
species shown by the by this arrow over
here so it's basically telling us how
much of this 5.5 s species is present in
the signal okay and it would give it
that would get out in signal units other
words it would get it out in absorbance
units in this case okay so other
important aspects of the CMS
distribution again I am basically it is
regularized so and that just allows us
to have a physically reasonable
distribution in other words it
suppresses high-frequency oscillations
in the distribution there okay so
if you have an XL I then you can always
also use laser interferometry to track
the signals therefore you have access to
either three or four symbols the okay so
how can we take advantage of this well
macromolecules will often respond to
interrogation a different wavelengths
characteristic we do their guinea
compositions in other words their
primary sequences so in other words for
example if we have proteins with
different ratios of tyrosine and
tryptophan those will respond
differently to different wavelengths
let's say 280 + 250 and those basically
those spectral signatures allow us to
track components uniquely so as you
might expect we need as many signals as
components and so if we're tracking two
things which is going to be the majority
of what I'm talking about today we at
least two signals the maximum number of
components of course being tracked in
the spectral index at y is 4 and i'm not
actually aware of anyone having done for
max and i've seen is three all right so
now in order to understand how multi
signal sedimentation velocity works at
least the approach that was pioneered by
peter shook we need to reexamine the CFS
distribution that actually make a new
kind of CMS distribution so we're going
to be examining multiple signals
multiple signals are going to be shown
over here the left side of this equation
and the basically we're going to be
globally analyzing more than one signal
so we have a sub lambda there as a
function of radius of time and that's
going to be a summation over all
components present so they might let's
say there are two components present
this large k here will be too we then
have our distributions being multiplied
by a perspective extinction coefficient
so we need to get into signal space and
actually our distribution here is going
to be yeah in concentration units now so
to give the signaling units we need
extinction information now the these sea
que VES distribution ctms distributions
will be scaling these lamb equation
solutions which are similar to before
but their respective to the specific
component alright so some key points
here we must have at least as many
signals as components k the signals will
be in life globally the ck of s
distributions overlap in s-space usually
we will have tan ok so again in my
examples there's going to be two cks
distributions and they're going to be
occupying the same parts of s space
because we have access to extinction
information the cks distribution that is
normalized such that if we integrate the
peak it reveals the concentration of
component k this extinction matrix that
are talking about must be non-singular
and i'll talk about that in a moment
also in this treatment hyper or hypo
chronicity has neglected okay so just to
illustrate these keep own heat
components again that the key point one
is that we have two components protein a
and protein B we need two signals and
these two signals are going to be
catalyzed globally here we see that our
two cks distributions are occupying
basically over
and in s-space in that if we integrate
them so if we integrate the blue one get
the area underneath it it's in this case
to micromolar the integral of the red
distribution it's going to give us five
month so the molar ratio of these Co
sentimental species is 2.5 to one so now
this actually gets to the what I want to
call the difference between molar ratio
of stoichiometry and that is that this
molar ratio is 2.5 to one but we're
really not going to have to have
molecules bound to one molecule so what
this probably means is that this was
five to two or ten to four complex and
you would get that information by
knowing the modeler molar masses 14a and
14b and then the molar mass that you got
from the hydrodynamic information that
we get from doing the gold acidification
experiment in velocity mode ok so now I
want to talk about this matrix of
extinction information so we have this
matrix if we have two components than
the extinction of component a the
different signals are shown by this
column vector here in that extend that
matrix and the extinction of commission
for component B is in that column vector
here so if we have a cartoon space here
where we have the extinction in a
wavelength one shown along this lie a
kiss and extinction at wavelengths to
show norvis x axis then we can represent
let's say the extinction for proof team
a as a vector in this space so
might have extinction wavelength one
this and that wavelength to all right
now let's say that we have another
component component being shown by the
blue vector that vector is exactly
collinear with the red vector and what
that means is that there's absolutely no
way that we can distinguish component a
four-component be this matrix is by
definition singular and the mathematical
way of describing that is that its
determinant is zero well so what we need
is a non singular matrix in other words
we need those vectors to be not
collinear but the real question then
becomes how nonlinear do they need to be
colleague of mine named shape Heydrich
got very interested in this question
when we started doing to the
sedimentation velocity multi signal
experiment together and you came up with
a metric that allowed us to have some
predictive value in figuring out whether
a given matrix will be non-singular
enough to basically allow us to do a
reasonable multi signal segmentation
velocity experiment so let's look at
this Cartesian space again and let's say
we have a vector for our routine a so
it's extinction properties look like
this and the extinction properties for
protein B look like this well if we take
vector a and we add it to vector B and
Victor being a vector a then we get
something that looks like this it's a
parallelogram and if we take the area of
that parallelogram that's actually the
determinant of that said that matrix
basic ok now the determinant by itself
is actually not very descriptive leaning
a way to normalize it so what we're
going to do is take the length of the
vector and the length of the blue vector
and we're going to multiply them and
that's kind of like getting this area
here okay so this area and if we divide
the determinant by the product of the
effective length we get this quantity
called the norm and be known as the
quantity of that che dreamed up that
allows us to figure out whether our
determinant is essentially large enough
for us to go forward with a
sedimentation velocity what's a signal
experiment after a lot of simulation we
determine that we want for typical
proteins and signal-to-noise ratios
women want to be norm of greater than
zero point zero six five percent our
sorry 0.065 and so you'll find actually
that if you're looking at protein
protein complexes that this is fairly
easily achieved in fact I have two fun
look pretty hard for proteins that
protein pairs that don't achieve this
okay so now that we've talked a lot
about theory of performing a
sedimentation velocity experiment let's
go forward and talk about planning and
performing these experiments so
questions for planning is long large
enough is the complex of Stan Zbornak
basically we want the complex to be
populated throughout the entire course
of the experiment which means we want
chaos to be slow or all you need and
something in significant molar excess
for us to be able to keep the complex
populated during the course of a
temptation velocity experiment what
signals will be on the concentration is
going to be within the minutes of
detection so these are basically the
limits of detection that we want to have
for absorbance and interfering topics
respectively and we want to be able to
build all the knowledge of the system
into the strategy and I think I'll be
touching on all these points on few
examples in the next few slides and one
thing I do want to add here is that the
signal increment for at least one signal
must be known as well we must know
extinction information before starting
to perform the analytical
desertification experiment for at least
one signal for all components okay so
that might be that you know the
extinction coefficient at 284 one of
your components very well from having
either attorney did empirically or
calculated okay so complex stability is
important we needed to be fully
populated throughout the experiment this
is not a problem for systems to have a
slow day off but for systems that have
fast k off which is probably most of
them the slow count means probably 10 to
the minus 5th per second and so there's
not a lot of pretty protein complexes
that would be interesting to study that
have that slow okay off and any rate
with a fast chaos basically what we need
is we need to choose concentrations that
fulfill our requirement usually this
means having a significant molar excess
of one of the components and most often
this is best achieved by having the
smaller of the two components in in
molar excess and that's just so that we
keep within the single limitations of
the choice of signals basically we want
to maximize the norm for if we're doing
an absorbance only experiment will
probably you want to look for different
ratios of truth depends of tyrosine
which will allow us to do a 282 250
experimental boards and monitoring the
experiment 289 years
or 250 navigators and again i'm talking
about proteins here for interference
absorbance we look at the front of
ratios of mass to trip thing because the
signal increment in interference optics
is do is basically directly proportional
to mass so we need basically if we have
different mass to tryptophan ratios and
then we can monitor ferent optics
observed 280 and that should allow us to
have different this going to large me
more also we want to choose signals so
that we're collecting peaks or valleys
and so this is a typical protein
absorbance profile here you would want
to if you are clicking absorbent only
experiment you would probably want to
collect it to two wavelengths that hide
it is highlighted here to 80 and 250 the
reason that you want to collect at
Pink's or values is that there's a
little bit of slop in the vector and
optics with regard to wavelength
accuracy and so if we're if we miss the
mark a little bit say we end up maybe
right here then we have not changing the
amplitude of the absorbance of Units
very much but if we we're on a shoulder
and we missed the mark a little bit
Hitler we're changing or amplitude by a
lot ok all right for a two-component
interaction usually three cementation
velocity experiments are necessary
component a by itself component being by
itself and the mixture of a B now
component the first two experiments are
necessary because we want to establish
the component s values and we also need
to refine extinction information so
remember we know extinction information
for one signal we're going to determine
extinction information for the other
signal in the centrifuge that's what
these first two experiments are for the
third experiment and of course is for
still economic
all experiments need to be monitor the
same signals the number of signals must
be at least 24 hour to component
interaction it can be more than to go if
possible it's best that if that we use
the same concentrations in experiments 1
and 2 that we used in two week this is a
very powerful control and this will come
out in the example analysis that i'm
going to do so my example here is a
published example only this is human
lactoferrin interacting with a bacterial
protein called TP 34 PP 34 we did an ITC
experiment and we got this ITC result
over here basically what I'm showing you
is that this has two modes in it and
obviously there were two binding events
we found that the molar ratio of
interaction was too too long so we
wanted to know what the real still kiama
tree was and we also wanted to confirm
this because basically this is a very
highly unanticipated result and we
wanted to be able to verify that using a
multi single sedimentation velocity
experiment now I should tell you the
human lactoferrin was from a commercial
source and it was expected to be like
oscillated therefore we because the
interference signal increment is due to
the mass we didn't know how much mass
there would be for human lactoferrin
because we didn't know the extent of my
constellation we therefore uses the
method of pace to figure out the
extinction coefficients for TP 34 and
human lactoferrin act at 280 nanometers
and so these are the values that we
needed
we chose to do interference observer to
280 because we felt that the mass two
trips family show is different enough
this is actually performed back before
we had being wrong to lean on so we
weren't we were just looking at mastic
tryptophan ratio and we basically did
those 37 tation velocity experiments
that I outlined a few slides ago
simultaneously in a single rotor at 20
degrees fifty thousand rpm okay and so
here are the results here is the data
tip for TP 34 the top shows the
absorbance data the body showed the
interference data and again these were
from exactly the same cell data were
collected concurrently during a single
run that said about the centrifuge the
human lactoferrin alone is shown here
again or absorbance on top interference
on the bottom then the mixture is shown
here and again you can see that we have
two boundaries one there and one there
so with a large molar excess of TP 34
that's the slower boundary and then the
faster boundary is the complex between
TP 34 and human life to fair so now that
we've collected the data we need to do
the analysis and so basically I'm going
to have to skip over a lot of steps
because I don't have time to really go
through all the nitty-gritty details of
understanding what how to import data
into said fat however there is a web
documentation how to do this what I've
done is loaded two experiments and
they're called experiment one over here
on the left and experiment two over here
on the right and this on the left is the
absorbance experiment and we're calling
that wavelength one interference is over
here on the right and we're calling it
way of length to the extent that program
calls it wavelengths even though of
course what we're collecting here is
interferometry I want to point out that
all of this is
in Peter ships program said fat and he's
the one who came up with a methodology
to do this computationally under the
model instead fat we choose
multi-wavelength discrete continuous
distribution analysis the program will
ask us as two wavelengths correct its
detective two experiments so things that
there are two signals we say yes and
then it asks if everything within the
standard configuration in other words is
set one wavelength one is set to
wavelength to etc we say yes we also
need to take particular care to have the
right experimental parameters in there
and that's accessed from the main menu
that said fat for the absorbent
experiment has put in this information
and this basically allowing baseline and
key I know is to refine the same
information is input for the
interference experiment shown over here
except we're also allowing really very
annoyed to refine here and that's just
standard for interference data what's
most important actually probably here is
I am NOT refining the menisci an empty
check button here and you've said that
means I'm not refining the value of
meniscus I set the meniscus when I
loaded the data in I'm not going to
infinite yet and that's because meniscus
refinement in the early stages when
conscious basically cost us a lot of
time so we want to keep that parameter
fixed and then we'll refine at a later
time now here is the global parameter
window and said that again access to the
main menu and it looks like a really
really horrible mess but it really isn't
it's organized very well and we're
actually only going to deal with a
subset of the windows here so for
example we're not going to use the top
part would because that's dude for
discrete species here we have the ck of
this information here's the extinction
information
and here is some ckn s properties that
will have to designate okay so looking
at the extinction part first for this
single species again this is component a
TP 34 by itself that I've loaded here so
I only have one species and that's
termed chromophore and the parlance of
said fact so I only have one chromophore
so my matrix only has one row in it
really it actually has two rows that
those might be zeros in the second row
now I've input the information that I
know which is the extinction at
wavelengths more which is the
interference I'm sorry which is the
absorbance I don't know the signal
increment for interference for TP 34 but
a good guess is 2.75 times the molar
mass of the protein note that i have
clicked on the refinement of this value
one of the big points of doing this
analysis by itself is that we need to
refine this number figure out what the
extinction is as wavelength too okay so
my next task is to figure out what
property the cks distribution is going
to have so I've turned on this segment
by checking this checkbox here now those
of you who are familiar with said fit
this one with this top row would look
pretty familiar to you I'm giving it a
resolution of 50 that means that i'm
going to be considering 50 sedimentation
coefficient values and they're they're
bound are 0.2 s and 10's i have input a
frictional ratio of 1.5 but again i'm
not allowing that to fit for the same
reason that i'm not allowing them in
this guide is it now down here we have
these two spectra the spectra are
actually in vc KMS distributions so i
told you that to an end to see KMS
distributions are going to have to
overlap
in one segment and so because we have
two signals it will allow you up to two
of those ck of s distributions however
we only have one component here TP 34
protein a and so I've only turned out in
one spectrum and now we have this kind
of what i would call MOS technology
matrix over here what I'm telling it is
that by putting it a a 1 here and a 0
here I'm telling said fact that spectrum
one is going to represent 120 complexes
of chromophore 12 chromophore to now of
course there is no chromophore to hear
but that is still important to put in
1m0 ok next we want our regularization
sand we click on this and you want the
distribution to be normalized so to
click on that all right so then we click
OK in that window and we would allow a
global fitting of the basically of the
distribution and now we get a ck a
single cks distribution down here then
represents TP 34 now we can immediately
see that this is pretty much a single
species and but the only thing that
we're really refining in this case was
this value right here which is the
signal increment for the interference
optics again that's wavelength to shown
there and so that's our initially
initially refined that was a little bit
higher than on what I thought it was but
it seems reasonable now again we're
throughout this we're going to have to
assess women to the fit to good or not
and I'm going to delay the discussion on
that until a later point in this talk
wind will and we'll sort of gloomily go
or where the fits are good or not but
take it from me that this fit at this
point is pretty good now what I need to
do is go back in the experiment
parameter with windows and turn all on
the menisci now I want these super fun
now that we have found a good value for
the single increment for the airfare
topics we can let other nonlinear
parameters were fine we would also want
to do that for the frictional ratio or
not to put in this line for that all
right so now we do another fitting and
this is the distribution that we did so
what did we learn from this distribution
well we learned that if I integrate over
the entire distribution I find that the
concentration of inputted TP 34 is 15.6
micromolar I'm going to want to note
that and write down somewhere the I also
found out what the signal increment the
final refined single increment for TP 34
at wavelengths to that is that for the
interference optics it and it's sixty
thousand eight hundred eighty seven
point three so those are the two
extremely valuable pieces of information
that I got out of this experiment and I
need to do that also for human life de
Ferran okay so this is the data loaded
into said fat for human lactoferrin I'm
not going to go through the process
again very very thoroughly because it's
very much analogous to what I did for TP
34 we would want to have our known
extinction information for wavelength
one in the absorbance and a guess for
wavelength too we're refining that in
this case I think that there's going to
be a little bit of aggregate present so
I put 15 as the maximum segmentation
coefficient but again since i'm defining
this human lactoferrin as criminal for 1
i'm only doing 120 complexes under the
spectra here this is after all the thing
of the distribution i get for human
lactoferrin and so as you might expect
for basically a commercially available
protein
from sigma or something it's not
perfectly pure but most of the material
is sedimenting here at the 5.5 s
position so what did I learn here I
learned that the total amount of input
signal concentration human lactoferrin
if we we can all of this I seem
lactoferrin is 1.8 micromolar and I also
learned the refined value of the single
increment for the airfare and optics
which is 230 2606 alright so now finally
the experiment that we need to analyze
is the mixture of the two so again you
can see that there are two boundaries
present and I've loved waiting like one
is in the absorbance data wavelength to
the air ference dinner now I'm going to
input the extinction information this
extinction information I know now here
having finding chromophore one is TP 34
but now I have two two chromophores
present two species present so
chromophore to is going to be defined as
human lactoferrin I've inputted the
extinction of the known extinction
coefficient of both human lactoferrin
sorry TP 34 and human lactoferrin here
and then the refining values for the
single increment and the interfere
topics here in here respectively for the
two proteins note that none of these
check boxes are checked because I don't
want this information to be refined
these need to be fixed ok so again I'm
chromophore one is TP 34 chromophore to
human lactoferrin ok now I'm don't be to
put off by this I'm actually splitting s
space into three segments here from
point
point2 24.8 s from five to seven s is
from 7.2 to 15 tests this is just a
matter of convenience for me to be able
to look at different regions of s face
with different parameters if necessary
but basically this is very similar than
what I did before with only one segment
now I need to define to spectrum
spectrum one is going to be examining
120 complexes a chromophore line to
chromophore to in other words in this ck
of s distribution to find my spectrum
one will be looking only for TP 34 so
that that ck of S curve will only
represent TP 34 the second seek a base
curve that occupied the same s space
will look for 021 complexes of
chromophore 12 chromophore to in other
words it will only report on the amount
of human lactoferrin present this matrix
is the same in all three segments
alright so after we do the global
fitting this is the result that we get
you can see now that we have this region
here of co sedimenting human lactoferrin
and TP 34 and the information on stokke
olive tree that we wanted is in there oh
I'm not going to tell you what the
answer is just yet I need you to take a
breath and delay the gratification for
just a moment because what we're going
to do is go over goodness-of-fit
criteria for these experiments and so
and again this would apply to all three
experiments that I've just shown you so
basically the first thing that we want
to assess is is chi-squared an rmsd okay
our destinies are shown at the top of
the windows here and here from my
absorbent and interference optics these
are actually very good numbers the the
global chi-squared global reduced chi
squared is shown here
and that is 0.26 in this case it's
difficult to give you a recommendation
for an absolute value there but you know
if this basically if the assumptions of
noise that went into the experiment are
correct then this should be you know
somewhere between 5 and 0.1 or something
but anyway this value of point 26 has me
not worried at all on the residuals
random and year 20 and for the most part
we can say that that's true the maybe a
little bit of systematicity and
absorbance residuals but for global
analysis this looks really good to me
you're the total concentrations of
capella doesn't match what we put in
this is where that concentration
information that we got some experiments
1 and 2 comes in handy if I integrate
under the entire distribution for this
note that this to signal analysis here
then what I end up getting is 15 and 2
now I thought that the input was going
to be 15.6 and 1.8 so those errors are
pretty small I'm thinking that this is
actually quite a good recapitulation of
the input concentrations and so it looks
to me like the analysis is working quite
well all right so now we get to gratify
ourselves with understanding the answer
if I integrate just under this region I
get a concentration of human lactoferrin
of 1.3 and of TP 34 I get 2.7 micromolar
so that is scarily close to two point
sorry to to the lung or 12 however you
want to think about it one he would like
to burn for every to TP 34 and when we
look at the hydrodynamic information
that we get from knowing that the
cementation coefficient is 6.5 roughly
here we can understand that this is
truly one human lactoferrin for to TP 34
the molar mass that we came out of that
is consistent with
that true molecular still kiama tree
okay so i just wanted to show you that
this this is an example from paper by
houghton analogous was performed in the
lab of peter shook and you can do this
with three signals and so this is the
three proteins freaking called lat one
called sauce and a medical curb the lat
was labeled with rhodamine and then i
believe in forum to 280 and interference
were also monitored and so three
components three signals and you can see
that you can actually get fairly good
resolution and have some guesses about
stoic geometry here okay so now in the
last few minutes that i have what i
wanted to do was she talked to you about
a system where the multi single
sedimentation velocity failed horribly
and this is a case again i think that
these cases are fairly rare but in this
case the norm was very very small 0.016
so i'd actually not very hard to find
something that bad but this actually
really compromises our ability to
spectrally decompose the C of s
distribution than to see KMS
distributions so if i do what i would
call an unconstrained analysis which is
exactly that i just showed you 1434
human lactoferrin i get an analysis like
this for TP 34 interacting with a
different protein called bovine
lactoferrin from ITC experiments we
understood that the stoic geometry of
this interaction was different it was
probably one to one at least the molar
ratio of interaction was one to one and
so we wanted to again confirm this using
the multi
methodology well when i do the
unconstrained analysis this is what i
get there are some big problems here
okay actually let me go back first of
all I want to point out that Boulevard
lactoferrin has a segmentation
coefficient by itself on about 5.2 s
well thin fat is telling me that on the
material below 4 s is actually Boulevard
lactoferrin that's physically impossible
so that's a sign that something had gone
horribly awry here sin that is also
telling me that the molar ratio of TP 34
and bovine lactoferrin is I don't know
what this is and it's probably something
like five to one but that doesn't make
hydrodynamics sense for proteins of this
size and so these two criteria tell me
that something is really really wrong
the other thing that tells me that
something's wrong is that the known
input concentrations shown here do not
match the calculated output
concentrations shown here and these are
actually rather large differences and so
in some cases up to something like
twenty to thirty percent so we basically
this is what failure looks like this is
a complete failure from the standpoint
of multi single cementation velocity and
that's because our game arm is just too
small alright so is there any hope for
rescuing this kind of experiment
actually wouldn't ask the question if
the answer wasn't yes so yes we can
introduce a new constraint in other
words that table that I showed you we
know the input concentrations we can
constrain the analysis tab or at least
should try to cleave to those
concentrations as closely as possible
this is called mass conservation multi
signal segmentation velocity or MCM ssv
note that when we use this as a
constraint we're losing it as a
call the assessment metric okay and then
the paper about this in plus one if you
want to check that out and again I refer
you to that paper for a lot of details
about this you were getting a little
short on time but what you would do to
do this analysis and the global
parameter window there's a little
section that has a width total
concentration prior knowledge so we
click on that check mark then we say sit
back I want you to enforce the input
concentrations which i inputted by hand
here to within whatever percentage and I
input five percent here I finger my
pipetting technique is good enough to
know the concentration plus or minus
five percent so what I've done then is
basically told you in analysis yes I
need to be constrained to plus or minus
five percent of the node input
concentrations now when I do the
analysis it turns out that there's still
this problem of there being not enough
spectral discrimination to say that the
stuff that is at 2's is really key p34
and not bovine like affair again the
molar ratio here turns out to be wrong
as well so we need to add in another
constraint and again this is another
example of adding in information when
you know it and you know it for sure so
the way to do this man is to split s
space up into two spaces and I showed
you how to do three spaces this is two
spaces here so I have one segment going
from zero point 2 24 s here now what
I've done is I've told said fat that
only TP 34 gets to be in this space open
like sounds too big to be here we
shouldn't detect any there so I've
turned off the second spectrum I said
said that I want to see only
TKS distribution here and it should be
120 complexes of chromophore 12
chromophore two in other words only TP
34 but I've allowed the cigna tune to
have both shown here okay so by building
in this information of knowing the TP 34
only TP 34 will be detected between 0.2
and 4s I'm helping the analysis out so
I'm constraining mass and I'm
constraining this smaller segment
segmentation coefficient range to
contain only TP 34 so now and have to
apologize I actually in incorrectly
human lactoferrin there so let's scratch
that that's going to be move on like
then little of the vision here on the
fly so now you can see that due to my
constraint we have only TP 34 down here
at small s values and now we have a co
sedimenting complex of bovine
lactoferrin and TP 34 at about 5.8 s the
molar ratio turns out to be 0.76 21
turns out that I probably didn't have
enough TP 34 in there to keep that
complex totally occupied during the
course of the Sanitation velocity
experiment and so this caused a slightly
strange molar ratio here however what's
interesting to note is actually went
back and did this experiment again it
turns out this is back before I'm going
to appreciate it
the need for Dean warm but I found that
if I collected the data at two signals
280 and 250 nanometers instead of
interference and a 280 which is what
this experiment is then I actually get a
much much better be norm something on
the range of 0.2 or something like that
now observe point2 0.02 much much better
spectral discrimination I can do the
unconstrained analysis and I end up
getting under identical conditions the
identical answer so I mean scarily
identical okay so the idea here is not
the mass constraints and the Sanitation
coefficient constraints that I put on
this analysis actually worked
beautifully okay so to conclude
basically I find multi signal
segmentation velocity VB to be a very
powerful means to discover the stoic
allergy of macromolecular complexes by
using the capabilities that are found in
current Beckman instrumentation and I
thought I think I've impressed on you
the careful experimental planning is
absolutely required it can be done in a
single rod of the AUC I think all of the
experiments I showed you we're done in a
single run of AC which basically means
24 hours of running maybe less and even
in these cases where we have challenging
spectral discrimination problems we can
get excellent results out so in the end
I do want to acknowledge the fact that
I'm not the inventor of this technique
by any stretch I'm just the conveyor of
it and so Peter shook has invented the
this pkms methodology way of looking at
multi cinnamon went to signal
segmentation velocity data and if you're
interested in doing this if you haven't
already done so i encourage you to
download said fat which will be found at
the link shown here
and if you liked how the graphs looked
on here virtually every two-dimensional
graph shown here including the ITC data
was made with my program gussy which you
can download at the link shown here just
a few acknowledgments Peter of course
the the proteins that I worked with
bovine lactoferrin human lactoferrin TP
34 well provided to me by Michael
norgaard slam here at UT southwestern
and in particular a brilliant protein
chemist named Ranjit Ditka and also I
want to reiterate the shape heydrich was
a major motivating force for getting the
norm metric going so with that I'm going
to turn the floor back over to channel
shorts and I'd be happy to take any
questions that you might have great
thank you for that terrific presentation
dr. broader Graham before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind remind our audience
that you can submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box that the lower left
the presentation window several good
questions already came in our first
question is can sample and complexes
that do not absorb in the UV or visible
spectrum be analyzed my initial thought
about that is probably no and the reason
is that you're going to need at least
two signals to be able to do this type
of experiment if you don't absorb at all
anywhere in the UV or visible region
then you've got a case where you've only
got one signal available to you and that
is the interference optical system but
because you only have the one signal I
do not think that this experimental
strategy would work for you great good
answer our next question is a can this
technique you be used proper actively
and what is the dynamic range
of a UC um I think it would be difficult
to use this technique prepara tipley and
and and that is because first of all the
the early parts of the analysis that i'm
talking about so-called experiments one
and two are very dependent on having
pure components and so if you had a
mixture of components that you were
trying to isolate or something that that
would not be a good strategy analytical
just immigration in general is not
considered to be a prepper give
methodology because basically retaining
the samples or getting the samples after
the experiment is problematic there
would be mixing as they would be taken
out of the rotor even if there wasn't
basically at the end point of the
experiment everything is pelleted at the
bottom of the certification cell so
there would actually be no separation or
prepper to value there so I I don't know
of anyone having used this as a property
of technique now i will say that one i
do know of one case where someone has
done I believe the sedimentation
equilibrium experiment and then taken
the supernatant from that experiment
which is not which is done at a much
lower gravitational field than a
segmentation velocity experiment and
then taking that material and done a
dynamic light scattering experiment on
that now that actually has a huge
advantage because by sedimenting for
several days in that experiment you have
really rigid yourself of contaminating
let's say a dust or something like that
and so you could the potential for
getting a very clean dynamic light
scattering signal ahead of the
supernatant from that kind of experiment
is is is is there and you might consider
that to be proper div great thank you
for that oh I missed the dynamic range
part sorry so the dynamic range is once
presented on one of my slides so you
need so because you're going to be using
the absorbance optics for at least one
signal you need to be within the
absorbance units limits for that so
generally I wouldn't want to be below
say about 0.1 absorbance units and when
do you want to be much above 1.0
absorbance units one does have to keep
in mind that in the Beckman centrifuge
usually the centerpieces have a path
length of one point two centimeters so
you're actually going to have 1.2 times
the value you would have in a one
centimeter path length that can also
sells centerpieces are thinner and that
actually allows you to explore wider
dynamic range so they are about a
quarter of the thickness so you could go
up to a sorbents of roughly four in that
case if you if you needed to okay thank
you for that our next question is a
method question if you collect it
absorbance 280 absorbers 250 and
interference for a two protein complex
is the use of all three of those optics
best or is it better to focus primarily
on the absorbance 280 and interference
and then the question follows up by
asking does using more signals make the
analysis longer
okay so taking the first part of that
question let's say you did three signals
for a two component problem I left I've
actually done that a couple of times and
if you look at the references that are
cited in this talk you'll see that I
have published data using that strategy
the question really becomes where is the
information content of the experiment
and so the two signals that gives you
the highest be norm are basically going
to be the ones that are contributing
most to the analysis to your ability to
discriminate between the between the two
components spectrally okay so if you
just did the analysis with the two
signals that gave you the highest being
warm that would be perfectly adequate
now if you collected all three signals
it doesn't really hurt to put in all
three from the standpoint of spectral
discrimination and it will probably help
you with regard to the basically the S
resolution that you get out because
given that you have collected three
signals if you leave out one of the
signals and then you're leaving out
actually part of the evolution of the
concentration profiles so I would
encourage you if you collect three
signals to go ahead and include them
does it slow down the analysis yes it
has the potential to because you're
including more data and more data means
more processing time now there's not
going to be really significant I don't
think so it would it would processing
time would not scare me away from doing
three signals and in fact if you were
really judicious about the range of
values that you use there were probably
be not a huge difference in the
of data points from a two single
analysis anyway so if you do go through
the pain to collect the three signals i
would use out three signals and not
really not hesitate to do so just
realizing that there's a strong
possibility that most of the spectral
discrimination is actually probably only
coming from two okay I think I just
think I've addressed both parts of that
question great terrific unfortunately
we're out of time today I want to thank
the audience for their interesting
question and participation in today's
event I also like to thank our sponsors
beckman coulter and of course dr. chad
brautigam for making today's educational
webcast possible which will also be
available for on-demand viewing through
beckman coulter com thanks again goodbye